it's good technique isn't it
how hard is that technique to pull off
well i can show you if you want
yeah let's do it i guess do it let's do
it
one and done
[Music]
hi i'm kevin de bruyne and this is raid
my skills for sport bible
wow
honestly the corn is pretty bad but he
controls it in the end just does a
retro
[Applause]
yeah bicycle kick so i'm just putting
top of the corner of uh
of
yeah of the course it's amazing i
couldn't even do that so
i just i mean that looks amazing that
girl
what's the best aesthetically pleasing
goal you ever sort of scored one that
you think looks amazing you know there's
an angle where uh score in the
quarterfinal of the world cup against
brazil and you know you see the ball is
just couple centimeters above the ground
so you see it in an angle where it just
flies into it so it's pretty nice to see
that one
that's brilliant
don't be in your phone dad
sorry
that's a new way of defending but if it
works it works doesn't it
who's the best defender you've played
with for cleveland country i think
probably one of the best that i've
played for a long time is company club
and country club and country so he's
like a big leader big personality
helped me in a lot of ways but he's been
important wherever i've been so
would you like to play under him one day
now he's a manager no
[Laughter]
how come
i don't know i think it would be weird
in a way so
i don't think that's gonna happen
oh bye-bye
[Laughter]
he was sick of all the tackles
that was amazing skill but he was just
frustration all that is there a player
that when you lined up against him for
another team that's you've got that sort
of skill you think oh god here we go i
would say one of the best in like
dribbling in that way is probably neymar
that i played against yeah
insane insane technique to dribble away
from from players and
he's quick he's
his mobility is amazing so he's
unbelievable
well i'm very happy that he didn't break
his foot there so
but you see he gets a strike as well i
got a strike so i'll say he's pretty
good at that
i'm not gonna try i'm gonna be honest
was there ever a sport that you look at
and you think i'd love to have been a
professional in that
oh if i could choose now i would say
golf oh really oh yeah it's wonderful
everywhere you go you're playing good
weather you see the whole world and then
you earn good money like why not make
sense what's your handicap oh no i don't
have any cop
i'm very bad
you just asked me if i could choose
oh wow
so
light blue kit
blonde hair left foot strike is that not
kevin de bruyne
that was me in disguise
he's fitter than me
that's an amazing like when you see the
angle of the of the goal you know when
it just goes in in the perfect
in the perfect way so for the camera is
brilliant
good jackass
[Applause]
the opponent he loses the ball and then
he just spins and not makes him in
between and then he goes on and gives a
cross one assist and they discourse
amazing
amazing bit of skill of this young man
oh god
that's a decent strike isn't it he just
went
full full risk and
yeah he just went top corner
i thought it is so bad
okay it's a big fail but yeah it's funny
for the others he's made he's still
laughing on the floor so of all your
teammates for for man city or belgium at
the moment who's most likely to to do
that in training i could see that
happening to jack or something greeley
yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if something
happens you know jack or phil yeah yeah
bernardo is a good shout out they just
goof around and the more you goof around
the more the more chances you have to
to
this sort of thing happening i don't
know if this exactly is gonna happen but
something can
it's good technique isn't it
how hard is that technique to pull off
well i can show you if you want
yeah let's do it let's do it let's do it
one and done
my third favorite clip of the day was uh
yeah the dad getting the big ball in his
balls
uh he's just funny
um the second one was the long-range
shot from the
the play in the white team it's just an
amazing strike and i think the first one
was the little kit with the with the
technique the nutmeg and the assist all
together so
yeah that's my favorite one
ah take the first one
let's be honest let's be honest
went into barcelona got rid of the big
names the ones that they said the
company ronaldinho ibrahimovic and all
that flipped football on it must have
been an absolute nightmare that i'm just
gonna decide to get rid of ronaldinho
he's not quite fitting what i want to do
as a manager oh my god absolutely taking
club management